خلونا بدايه نستمع لاراء السعوديين حول
هذا الموضوع موضوع النسيان
والله اكيد
من اول كان الواحد يستخدم اشياء في جسمها
في حركته في الان استخدم الافتراضي كل شيء
يقضيه
بالتطبيق يقضيه بالتلفون يقضي فاختلف
الوضع يعني
من الطبيعي انه يصير شويه من استخدامها
التطبيقات السريعه اولا يعني الناس
الاولين يعني مروا على ضغوطات ولا مشاكل
ولا شيء اما الزمن هذا تحس بضغوطات اكبر
المسؤوليه اكبر وتحس انك اصابك
شاف احد في العائله وصعب زهايمر بس مبكر
فسار يخاف انه ممكن هو يصاب بالزهايمر
والله انا اشوف ظروف الحياه
المسؤوليات ايضا اللي تحاط به يعني متوقع
كل شخص وله ظرف ممكن هو اللي يعدينا مصاب
بالزهايمر شوف ممكن انه العامل النفسي
تاثير يعني العامل النفسي تاثير بنسبه
كبيره
يصاب بالزهايمر لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على يوتيوب
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات